[Musique]
datant s'il te plaît rentre regarde
ça y est c'est bon
oui
c'est juste à côté
cha cha cha cha aucun d'entre eux n'a
été pris
deux jours
ils ont tout faux il ya des tonnes de
fragments qui vont arriver et ils disent
que l'un d'entre eux va détruire la
terre les avions qui sont pas militaires
doivent rester au sol qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
ce serial je sais même pas si cette
histoire d'abris que je dois rejoindre
c'est vrai ou pas n'importe quoi tu le
sais très bien [ __ ]
désolé je m'excuse auquel je m'excuse
c'est jusqu'à s'il te plaît appel nous
si tu trouves un endroit sûr où protéger
ta famille pour qu'on puisse se mettre
en sécurité
bien sûr que je serai jamais un débris
de petite taille de répercuter le nord
de l'état de new york s'est alors mis à
l'abri
[Musique]
oh mon dieu
cette fois là
on attend
bien avec nous s'il te plaît non
pourquoi têtu comme une mule vient cet
ep puymaurin si tu restes ici
oui ça je sais aujourd'hui demain dans
dix ans a fait aucune différence pour
moi c'est dans cette maison que mammeri
est allé au paradis
parce que le seigneur jugera qu'il est
temps que je le rejoins que je me
tiendrais ici dans cette maison c'est
tout prêt à partir
nathan
c'est un gars qui dit que c'était
fragile il faut pas travailler on y va
nous venons d'apprendre que le fragment
vient de percuter le centre de la
floride
au monde il ne s'agit pas d'une tempête
que tu peux gérer les agences spatiales
qui suivent clark depuis le début
président d'un niveau d'extinction qui
devrait s'étendre à toute la planète
c'est un cybercentre et courage à tous
ici
je le jure je vais conduire ma famille
dans ce broker
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il ya si vous entendez ce
message chercher un refuge timide
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'en sais rien
les agences spatiales parle d'une
possible extinction
il paraît que des avions militaires
volver des bunkers au groenland
je vais conduire ma famille dans ce bout
y chercher un refuge
cherchez un refus immédiat les médias
votre maître vous a parlé de cette chose
oui savait que clark venait d'un autre
système solaire c'est pour ça qu'on
s'est lancé il ya de fortes chances que
le spectacle est impressionnant regarde
les seniors les agences spatiales parle
d'une possible extinction
il paraît que des avions militaires vols
vers des bunkers groenland
je vais conduire ma famille dans ce
bouquin chercher un refuge immédiate
chercher à rôtir
immédiatement nous venons d'apprendre
que le fragment vient de percuter le
centre de la floride
ils ont dit des conneries clark
surnommés les chasseurs de planètes
je le jure je fais conduire ma famille
dans ce bunker
nous venons d'apprendre que le fragment
vient de percuter le centre de la
floride
oh mon dieu c'est ch pas d'une tempête
que tu peux gérer les agences spatiales
qui suivent clark depuis le début
prédisent un niveau d'extinction qui
devrait s'étendre à toute la planète
c'est un adversaire très correct il 6
je le jure je vais conduire ma famille
dans ce broker
la seule chose dont les gens parlent
aujourd'hui c'est clark la comète à pen
helen clark et la une des médias grosse
info je vois pas clark
il est peut-être en train de dormir papa
elle est le gros fragment de la coved
clark vont très bientôt entrer dans
notre atmosphère
tout à fait et il ya un soin de fortes
charges toujours pense que le spectacle
soit impressionnant ou est ce qu'il voit
jean sérère un des premiers morceaux va
s'écraser s'écraser un petit morceau et
ce sera dans l'eau sert de nom à
regarder ça
eh ben ça n'a pas explosé
nous venons d'apprendre que le fragment
vient de percuter le centre de la
floride
attendez il va y en avoir encore
d'autres allait bien on s'en va en
guerre nous il ya deux jours ils ont dit
des conneries il y aura d'autres
fragments qui vont détruire la terre les
agences spatiales parle d'une possible
expulsion
on va affronter son ensemble auquel un
grand faut juste qu'on trouve un refuge
[Musique]
des avions militaires vols vers des
bunkers au groenland c'est notre seule
chance
ok je l'assumé
à lutter
oui bah on veut trouver le plus gros
fragment de claque va s'écraser dans
moins de vingt quatre heures je le jure
je vais conduire de famille de ce
blogueur je suis sûr fiston
si vous entendez ce message chercher un
refuge immédiatement qu'est-ce qu'il ya
qu'est ce qui se passe si vous entendez
ce message est rassasié
accroche-toi aux attentes
jeudi médias qu elle cherchait un refus
immédiat